supplement should I take to lower my homocysteine levels. So, homocysteine is a
metabolite that later changes to cysteine and goes into the cycle to help
produce glutathione among other things. It's the endpoint of what's called the
methionine cycle and it can be elevated because of deficiencies in methyl groups. So
typically a person has elevated homocysteine you want to increase methyl groups which
typically is contradictory for cancer patients. So, cancer patients don't necessarily want to
add exogenous methyl groups. You don't want to take supplements that have methyl folate,
methyl tetrahedral folate or methylcobolamine because excess methyl groups
combined to and silenced tuber suppressor genes thereby allowing cancers to
continue to flourish. So, their silencing are turned off to tuber suppressor genes and your
tumor suppressor gene system is the intrinsic made inside the cell way that your body will
kill, destroy cancer cells. So, you'll have an internal switch inside each cell if a cancer,
if a cell becomes a cancer cell, then it goes into rapid replication. By tumor suppressor genes
that will turn out and stimulate apoptotic or cell death cycles inside the cell.
Excess methyl groups if I'm taking methylcobolamine, methyl tetrahedral folate because
you know my nutritionists told me and I should take that,
then that can actually be something that could propagate a cancer. So,
and that can be part of a reason why a person has a cancer and it gets a diagnosed cancer because
they were taking that indirectly. So, the only reason why I would have somebody take methyl groups is
if we did a blood test or they had elevated levels of homocysteine. Homocysteine again is a metabolite
that then converts to, it's like it converts to us another metabolite, another intermediate
metabolite goes in through the CTH gene and breaks down into cystine and then it helps produce glutathione
and cystine sulfate and some other different intermediate metabolites. But if a person has
elevated homocysteine, it can damage the internal lighting of your vessels so it can damage the
endothelial layer and that's what can end up causing your body will try to heal that through cholesterol,
placid and cholesterol gets the band A's and that's becoming the bandline. And that's what can
block arteries and it's really not cholesterol's fault, it's an elevation of the homocysteine. So,
getting homocysteine levels checked is a good idea. Now, it's not always a part of a comprehensive
metabolic profile so many times you need to request that. So, getting homocysteine levels checked
is a good idea. If your homocysteine is within normal limits, then I would not use exogenous
methyl groups. Regardless of whether if you have MTHFR, gene defects or not. Again, for those that
have been with me for a long time, you've heard me talk about MTHFR, methyl tetrahydrofolate reductase
gene and many people that ignorantly just take methyl groups because they have an MTHFR gene,
defect, thinking that because I had that defect, I need to be taking methyl groups. I think that's
incorrect on many levels and it could be actually dangerous. Not just for propagated cancer,
but it pushes the biopter and pathway to cause excess serotonin and dopamine levels, especially if you
have defects in the genes in different genes in the biopter and pathway, the COTG, the MAO gene.
And the other pathways that lead to dopamine production.
So, but if you do have elevated homocysteine that I would say you take methyl groups for a period
time, you recheck and you play with your dosage based upon that homocysteine level.